good afternoon
last week in the immediate aftermath of
the incursion by China's high altitude
balloon
our military through the North American
Aerospace Defense command so-called
North NORAD
closely scrutinized
the our airspace including enhancing our
radar to pick up more slow moving
objects above our country
around the world in doing so they
attract three unidentified objects one
Alaska Canada and over Lake Huron in the
Midwest
they acted in accordance with
established parameters for determining
how to deal with unidentified aerial
objects in U.S airspace
at third recommendation I gave the order
to take down these three objects due to
hazards to civilian commercial air
traffic and because we could not rule
out the surveillance risk of sensitive
facilities
we acted in consultation with the
Canadian government I spoke personally
with prime minister Trudeau and cam from
Canada on Saturday
and just as critically we acted out of
an abundance of caution and an
opportunity that allowed us to take down
these these objects safely
our military and the Canadian military
are seeking to recover the debris so we
can learn more about these three objects
our intelligence Community is still
assessing all three incidences they're
reporting to me daily and will continue
their urgent efforts to do so and I will
communicate that to the Congress
we don't yet know exactly what these
three objects were but nothing nothing
right now suggests they were related to
China's spy balloon program or that
there were surveillance vehicles from
other any other country
the intelligence community's current
assessment is that these three objects
were most likely balloons tied to
private companies Recreation or research
institutions studied weather or
conducting other scientific research
when I came into office I instructed our
intelligence Community to take a broad
look at the phenomenon of unidentified
aerial objects
we know that a range of entities
including countries companies and
research organizations operate objects
at altitudes for purposes that are not
nefarious including legitimate
scientific research I want to be clear
we don't have any evidence that there
has been a sudden increase in the number
of objects in the sky we're now just
seeing more of them partially because
the steps we've taken to increase our
Radars to narrow our radars and we have
to keep adapting our approach to uh
delaying to dealing with these
challenges that's why I've directed my
team to come back to me with sharper
rules for how we will deal with these
unidentified objects moving forward
distinguishing distinguishing between
those that are likely to pose Safety and
Security risk that necessitate action
and those that do not
but make no mistake
if any object presents a threat to the
safety security of the American people I
will take it down
I'll be sharing with Congress these
classified policy parameters when
they're completed and they'll remain
classified so we don't give a road map
to our enemies to try to evade our
defenses
going forward these parameters will
guide what actions will take while
responding to unmanned and unidentified
aerial objects we're going to keep
adapting them as the challenges evolve
if it evolves in addition we drive
direct to my National Security advisor
to lead a government-wide effort to make
sure we are positioned to deal safely
and effectively with the objects in our
airspace
first we will establish a better
inventory of unmanned Airborne objects
in space above the United States
airspace and make sure that inventory is
accessible and up to date
second we'll Implement further measures
to improve our capacity to detect
unmanned objective objects in our
airspace
third we'll update the rules and
regulations for launching and
maintaining unmanned objects in the
skies above the United States of America
and fourth my secretary of state will
lead an effort to help establish a
global a global common Global norms and
this largely unregulated space
these steps will lead to safer and more
secure skies for our air Travelers our
military our scientists and for people
on the ground as well
that's my job as your president
commander-in-chief
as the events of the previous days have
shown will always act to protect the
interest of the American people on the
security of the American people
since I came to office we've developed
the ability to identify track and study
high altitude surveillance balloons
connected with the Chinese military
when one of these high altitude
surveillance balloons entered our
airspace over the continental United
States earlier in the month I gave the
order to shoot it down as soon as it
would be safe to do so the military
advised again shooting it down over land
because of the sheer size of it was the
size of multiple school buses and
opposed the risk to people on the ground
if it was shot down where people lived
instead we tracked it closely we
analyzed its capabilities and we learned
more about how it operates and because
we knew its path we were able to protect
sensitive sites against collection
we waited until it was safely over water
which would not only protect civilians
but also enable us to recover
substantial components for further
analysts for for further Analytics and
then we shot it down sending a clear
message clear message the violation of
our sovereignty is unacceptable
we'll act to protect our country and we
did
now this past Friday we put restrictions
on six firms that directly support the
People's Republic Liberation Army
people's lib the people's Liberation
Army Aerospace program that includes
airships and balloons denying them
access to U.S technology
we briefed our diplomatic partners and
our allies around the world and we know
about China's program and where their
balloons have flown
some of them have also raised their
concerns directly with China
our exports have lifted components of
the Chinese balloon's payload off the
ocean floor
we're analyzing them as I speak and what
we learn will strengthen our
capabilities
now we'll also continue to engage with
China as we have throughout the past two
weeks as I've said since the beginning
of my Administration we seek competition
not conflict with China we're not
looking for a new Cold War but I make no
apologize I make no apologies and we
will compete and will be will
responsibly manage that competition so
that it doesn't Veer into conflict
this episode underscores the importance
of maintaining open lines of
communication between our diplomats and
our military professionals
our diplomats will be engaging further
and I will remain in communication with
President XI
I'm grateful for the work of the last
several weeks of our intelligence
diplomatic and Military professionals
who approve once again to be the most
capable in the world
and I want to thank you all now look the
other thing I want to point out is that
we are going to keep our allies and the
Congress contemporaneously inform to all
we know and all we learn and I expect to
be speaking with President XI and I hope
we have come we are going to get to the
bottom of this but I make no apologies
for taking down that balloon thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
sir the question
sir there's been criticism there's been
criticism that this wasn't there's been
criticism that this really trying to
compromise by your family's business
relationship Sir Mr President Mr
President there has been criticism
Mr President there has been criticism
that this was an overreaction that was
done because of political pressure
you've turned my off and that's the
question when you have more polite
people Mr President why have you chosen
Poland for your trip to Mark and sorry
of the world
message